as abortion activists firebomb pro-life
offices and pregnancy centers in
wisconsin in oregon in maryland and
elsewhere around the country the white
house is continuing to insist that the
pro-abortion protests have been peaceful
and should continue
even when they take place at judges
homes
so i know that there's an outrage right
now i guess about
protests that have been peaceful to date
and we certainly continue to encourage
that outside of judges homes and that's
the president's position
i actually cannot quite believe what she
is saying here is jen saki saying that
the white house is encouraging the
protests outside the supreme court
justice's homes meaning the protests
that are occurring at those homes
or is she saying that the white house is
encouraging protests outside of meaning
other than or except for the ones at the
judge's homes i hope it's the latter
i've been trying to figure out how to
make it be the latter
but i just don't think it is
i don't think it is because the other
day when saki was asked directly about
the very same protests she refused to
condemn them she said that the she
doesn't have an official government
position on where people protest
i don't think she is saying except for
the judge's homes because today she's
still pretending that the pro-abortion
protests are peaceful despite the
graffiti and the arson around the
country
despite the shrieking mobs outside of
the justices homes where their children
sleep
i don't think
that it's the latter i don't think she's
saying don't go to the judge's homes
because the protests at judges homes
or to influence their decision in this
case are in violation of federal law and
the white house won't say anything about
that i don't believe that gensake is
condemning these protests
because when blm was burning the country
down senior officials in this
administration were raising money to
bail out the rioters
the left is right about one
thing in this whole mess
they are right that we are witnessing a
constitutional crisis
not because the supreme court might
overrule a terrible decision from the
1970s
but a constitutional crisis because the
executive branch is waging war on the
judiciary
the left is willing to tear down the
most fundamental aspects of our system
of government
the left is saying the quiet part out
loud specifically the pro-abortion left
where there's really not a distinction
these days it used to be that you could
be on the left but oppose abortion i
think that's pretty much gone by the
wayside
it certainly used to be that you could
be a democrat and oppose abortion
that's been gone now
it seems almost entirely gone and it's
it's been extremely
unpopular for 30 years and really
starting with mario cuomo andrew cuomo's
father when he was governor of new york
he invented this idea of i'm personally
opposed to abortion but politically i
support it which doesn't make any sense
at all if you think it's murder then it
should be illegal if you don't think
it's murder then why do you oppose it if
it's just like taking your appendix out
then who cares it's not a big deal it
was always incoherent so so i use these
for the left or the democrats or the
pro-abortion activists
today 99.9 of the time they all refer to
the same group of people and they are
saying the quiet part out loud okay
when jin zaki comes out and she says
yeah we encourage protests outside of
judges homes
she's she's saying what we already knew
the the white house believed
if she misspoke i hope she clarifies it
today but i don't think she did
because
the
in in practice the white house has been
encouraging all of these protests so i'm
not surprised that she says yes we're
encouraging them janet yellen who is the
treasury secretary for joe biden she
came out and voiced her opinion on
abortion seems kind of crazy right who
cares what the treasury secretary has to
say about constitutional law and the
bioethical question of abortion who care
well
janet yellen cares and actually she
exposes one of the reasons why corporate
america the kind of big corporate
establishment is so gung-ho on
supporting their employees to go travel
out of state to get an abortion to
support to oppose the overrule of roe
versus wade janet yellen makes the
argument that if we if we have fewer
abortions we're not going to make as
much money i believe that eliminating
the right of women to make decisions
about when and whether to have children
would have very damaging effects
on the economy and would set women back
decades
roe v wade and access to reproductive
health care including abortion
helped lead to increased labor force
participation
it enabled
many women to finish school that
increased their earning potential it
allowed women to plan and balance their
families and careers and research also
shows that it had a favorable impact
on the well-being and earnings
of of children
if i wrote a script about the
pro-abortion side
and i
i just wrote exactly what janet yellen
just said her argument for more abortion
and i turned it into a producer in
hollywood they would reject the script
for it being too cartoonishly villainous
they would reject it probably because of
the politics of the script too but they
would reject it because of the writing
because what she just said is is such a
caricature
of an evil villain to say well it is my
opinion that we need to continue to kill
875
000 babies a year because if we kill
fewer of those babies we might not make
as much money and then we won't be able
to buy as much stuff
and then we won't have lots of fun toys
and jewelry and gems and gold and money
we have to kill the babies so we can
have more money that is my reasoned
opinion as the treasury secretary
and then just when you think she's going
to start making some other kind of
that's her primary argument well okay
then she talks about the effect on women
maybe she's just an ideological leftist
too she's it's really important for
women's well-being
in the labor force
in the labor force for women's
well-being in their earnings potential
so it's just about money you're saying
we need to sacrifice our babies so that
we can make more money
i think that's a bad deal i don't think
we should do that i'm willing to
diminish the gdp of the united states if
it means we don't slaughter upwards of a
million babies a year call me crazy call
me old-fashioned
that's not even old-fashioned every
evil pagan tribe in the history of the
world has has practiced human sacrifice
to try to grow their riches okay and the
united states right now with this woman
as the treasury secretary with this
government that we've got in place is
doing exactly the same thing
and they they probably don't even see it
they think that they're they're really
fancy and sophisticated and modern and
they just understand things no they're
doing the same damn thing that awful
tribes have done for all of human
history sacrifice their kids to moloch
so that they can
sacrifice their kids to mammon really
mammon and so that they can have more
stuff
i think that's a bad i think it's pretty
evil
when you really think about it don't you
i think it is but they're saying they
used to mean that
but they wouldn't say that and it really
throws this into perspective why is
amazon paying for their employees to go
out of state to get abortions because it
helps their bottom line because it helps
amazon make more money beyond the woke
takeover of amazon or the woke people at
tesla
tesla's got the same policy i'm sure a
lot of other corporations are going to
have the same policy beyond the the wild
ideological takeover there's a cold hard
cash capitalist element here too which
is they want to make more money kids are
expensive they cause women to not work
as hard they cause women to take a lot
of time off from work they cause women
to be less reliable in the workplace
because maybe little johnny gets sick
one day and they're not able to come to
that meeting on tuesday and so if you
kill the kid then then you've got a much
more reliable workforce then you get
much more man-hours out of them it'll
it'll really increase labor
participation that's literally what the
treasury secretary said it's evil it is
i don't throw that word around lightly
it is evil it is hideous it is inhumane
but it's the argument that they are
making explicitly glad you like that
clip now
ring that smash
like that subscribe click that whatever
you got to click subscribe make sure you
get the notifications head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitch your google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe over there as well if you
don't mind leave a five star review we
will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]